[Musique]
on les surnomme des bébés dragons
c'est salamandre des grottes sont
connues depuis des siècles mais en
vienne leur découvrir un nouveau fait
d'armes
la capacité de ne faire absolument rien
pendant des années
[Musique]
complètement aveugle et albinos cette
espèce vit dans les grottes de rap
elle est même la vedette d'une des plus
spectaculaire d'entre elles situées en
slovénie des chercheurs ont observé que
la plupart parcours à peine quelques
mètres par année est la plus sédentaire
est resté exactement au même endroit
pendant sept ans la raison est simple
c'est que la nourriture est rare
[Applaudissements]
la salamandre détecte les mouvements de
ses proies grâce à sa peau ultra
sensible et quand l'une d'elles passe à
proximité
la salamandre peut être vifs comme
l'éclair elle peut ensuite survivre des
années sans manger
cette stratégie de conservation
d'énergie extrême lui permet de vivre
jusqu'à 100 ans la salamandre des
grottes se reproduit en moyenne une fois
par décennie ce qui contribue à en faire
une espèce menacée
des biologistes tendon d'accélérer un
peu les choses
en séparant les femelles qui viennent de
pondre on évite que leurs oeufs soit
attaquée par une voisine affamés autres
ou territoriale ces efforts semblent
porter fruit
il ya quelques années on a pu assister
en direct à toute première éclosion de c
ceux des bébés dragons pour qui la vie
espérons le sera un long fleuve
tranquille
[Musique]